今日1初店長です
動画のタイトルにもあります通り
しますはじめした等のチャンネルを休止さ
せていただきます
ちょっとだけなんだけどちょっとというか
ちょっとというかまぁそんななんか何ヶ月
もとかそういう感じじゃないしなんかとは
思ってる短いと思うんですけど一応
アナウンスしておかなければいけないなと
思って動画を撮らせていただいております
今月は弾みさそうです
1回ちょっと休憩したいなっていう話です
本当にそれだけあの本当に皆様のおかげで
チャンネル登録者数1000万人も今
1010万人かな1010万人かせて
いただいております本当にありがとう
ございます
12月
まあ正直言うとかなり自分にムチを打って
走った結果
楽しかったです誰だ楽しかったでがまあ
無理したというか結構集めたな生活が続い
ててなんかこのは1000万人突破した後
もチンタラチンタラやっていても何か違う
なぁと正直思っておりましてお休みを
いただくコーナーでそういうつもりはあり
ませんねんか機能を実は2日間その後旅行
行ってきてねもう休みは終わったもう奴に
終わったんですけれども準備期間なんか
久々にね何も考えずに休むと脳が結構で
嫉妬されたんですよすっきりしてで年か
このまま動画をねこのままいつも通り
どうぞ続けるより1回休んでなんか準備
期間を設けるというか色々とねちょっと
裏方の人とかスタッフとかも含め話やいい
というか準備する期間を設けたいなと思い
そして1回ちょっとお休みさせていただき
ます楽しみに待ってくださっている皆さん
ほんとすいませんかこの動画を見て下さい
休みたくなっちゃったとかそういうわけで
もないです多分普通に貯め撮りとか撮影を
すると思うんであの街で見かけた際には
ぜひぜひ肇社長って離さオミクロンだから
ほどほどについて下さいお願います全然
見かけると思って食べチャンネルも
もちろんやりますショート動画多分投稿数
いうかなちゃんとしたメインチャンネルの
動画っていうのはちょっとお休みしたいな
と思っておりますのでちょっとね色々を
変えたいんだよねー
動画の作り方とか考え方というかなんで
このタイミングで休もうかと思ったかと
いうとなんか占い師てやると2月がすごい
なが爆発するつきって言われてたんでじゃ
じゃあいつ休むなんか5考えればいいの
かっていうともう今しかないと思って
ちょっと1月かな1月の後半というかあれ
ばそんな超休むつもりはないんですよほど
準備がとっそろったらいつでもスター武将
が思ってるんですけどて来い力を生み出す
には準備期間が必要だと思ってるんでその
ちょっと準備期間として1月の木寸ぐらい
までちょっとチャンネルお休みさせて
いただきたいなと思っておりますいろいろ
改善したいなと思いましてもう全部心機
一転1回脳みそでゲットして新しいはじめ
シャツを
1月の後半か2月ぐらいからお見せできれ
ばいいなと思ってちょっとお休みさせて
いただきますなんかだか体調がおり調査が
リーナがメンタルが壊れたとかなんか全然
そういうのではないんでマジであの本当に
前向きな奴なんでそこはあの心配しないで
くださいあっ成人された皆様おめでとう
ございますというわけで
多い必ずパワーアップして帰ってくるから
ぜひ待ってください
という豚が続いてきますじゃ